هل من الممكن أن يتمتع الأوليغارشية
بالقوة الكافية
التي تمكنهم من الضغط على بوتين
لتغيير مسارهم للانسحاب من
أوكرانيا
أه
هذا
خطأ
افتراض خاطئ
حول كيفية
ترتيب
القوة الروسية.
ليس القلة ولكن
مجرد عملاء الكرملين
الذين يستخدمهم الكرملين كأداة لذلك
لا توجد ردود فعل في
الاتجاه الآخر للتأثير على الديكتاتور
فهم لا يستطيعون فعل ذلك
بالمعنى العملي
أم
ماذا عن
أه الجيش أو
أجزاء أخرى من  أه النخبة الحاكمة
ربما في الكي جي بي ما هو الآن FSB
هي أجهزة المخابرات أو
الجيش هل لدى أي شخص قوة
غيرك تعرف بوتين يطلق على نفسه
القوة الرأسية هل هناك أي شخص
خارج هذا العمودي
للسلطة التي
يحملها بوتين  إلى السلطة من
خلال أه أخذ أجزاء من الناس من
حوله وجعلهم في
مواجهة بعضهم
البعض بالطبع هناك أناس لديهم
بعض  التأثير على
تصوراته العقلية ،
أناس مثل يوري كوفالتشوك وأولئك
الذين هم حوله yurikovalchuk
وبالطبع الجيش
لا يستطيع إخبار بوتين وهم بالفعل
يقولون له الآن أننا
في الظروف الحالية لا نستطيع
القيام بالمهام التي كلفنا بها
وعلى بوتين أن يأخذ ذلك في الحسبان ،
لكن القرار اتخذه
بالطبع ،
فما السبيل للضغط على
روسيا
لتصبح جادة على طاولة المفاوضات
للأسف
لا
يمكن تقديم نصيحة أخرى هنا
سوى شجاعة الأوكرانيين
والعقوبات.
هذا
يقوض فرص بوتين
لشراء
أسلحة جديدة وتوظيف مرتزقة بالنظر إلى ما
تعرفه عن عقليته ، ما الذي
سيفعله
هو أنه سوف يحول أوكرانيا إلى
الشيشان ويدمرها ، هل سيتراجع
عما سيفعل؟  كنت تعتقد أن خياراته
أه
بالنسبة له الوضع اليوم معقد للغاية
في البداية ما أراده هو
تغيير القوة في كييف ووضع
دميته وكان يتوقع
أن
هذا سيقابل بالورود التي
ألقاها الشعب الأوكراني في الشوارع
عندما لم يحدث ذلك ،
لقد جن
جنون حقيقة أن الناس في هاركوف لم يقابلوه بالزهور ،
لم يغضبه فقط ،
أعتقد حقًا أنه دفعه حرفياً
مجنون عندما بدأ قصف
خاركيف
وكييف الآن ، لديه ثلاثة خيارات
تواجهه بثلاث
طرق للخروج أولاً
هو الاستمرار في الضغط على
أوكرانيا وربما خسارة القوات
في هذه العملية لأن
الأوكرانيين يقاتلون بقوة أكبر من أي وقت مضى
كل يوم
ثانيًا.  يمكنه
استخدام أسلحة الدمار
الشامل على أمل أن
يجبر هذا الأوكرانيين على التراجع
والخيار الثالث
هو
بدء مفاوضات فعلية عندما يقول السيد بايدن
عندما يقول مسؤولو الناتو ذلك
بصوت واحد
إذا
استخدم السيد بوتين
إذا استخدمت wmds فسوف تحصل على
رد مناسب من الناتو
يعطي في الواقع خيارًا واحدًا فقط
للجلوس بشكل حقيقي على طاولة المفاوضات